younger Royals they are speaking out
about a tragedy nearly 20 years ago that
is one of our headlines this morning
Britain's Telegraph reports on Prince
William and Prince Harry joining the
Duchess of Cambridge to talk about
Princess Diana's death I do think it's
incredible how strong and how you've
been able to to cope ready and I put
that down to your moody early years
childhood experience we have been
brought closer because of the
circumstances as well that's the thing
anything you are you know uniquely and
bonded because of what we've been
through one and but you know even her
and I over the years and not talked
enough about it I know our mother you
know we've never enough history in this
campaign sort of me to realize that yeah
I think so I always thought to myself
you know what's the point of bringing up
the past what's the point in bringing up
something that's only gonna make you sad
and ain't gonna change it it ain't gonna
bring her back
well Kensington Palace released a film
to promote the young royals mental
health campaign that is so unusual to
see the three of them yes like we're
eavesdropping on a conversation that
there have it's so personal and so
unusual because it's so personal yeah
right at that point that that Prince
Harry just made the idea that you're
bringing up something to remind it's you
know you're reminded of it no matter we
don't avoid it that's right we don't
avoid it about it